you started in Star Wars rogue one and
such a great role but then spoiler alert
and and you know block yours if you
don't know but everyone saw this movie
your character died very haunting moment
yeah how did your kids handle that first
of all you're in a Star Wars film so
they must have been like imagine it was
like an hour and 45 minutes I was the
best dad right but that suddenly was
like my son was miserable my daughter
was asleep in the premiere so five years
old okay well she's 32
she just didn't love it yeah no but my
son was devastated he was like you're
the worst yeah it was so close to heaven
but now it's like you're done who's in a
film that dies in the first one you know
right if you were if you were if your
cartridge stayed alive then it's yeah
you get to be in the nets and the nets
and the next and the next so your son
was pissed he was pissed off he looked
at me like you
[Applause]
he didn't say well you're raising him
well yeah he didn't say it and gladly he
doesn't watch your show that I know but
yeah he was he was looking at me like oh
go back to your Mexican dirty feel right
now
but now this is great now you're coming
back for the Disney plus series oh yeah
and it's a prequel
calcium's back you're back for the
prequel series so you're reunited with
your robot friend who's Alan Tudyk right
Alan Tudyk he's he's hilarious huge yes
he's big like you are yeah yeah you
probably wouldn't not have this problem
if you acted with him but I did like
because the robot is big so he was
wearing stilts and and that's also what
they did is they to create me because
they could have just animated the whole
thing but they tried a [ __ ] because I
had to interact with his balls through
the hole he's on stilts his son steals
and what's he wearing a tight pajamas oh
no it's very graphic yeah and his face
is there but but it's like whoa I was
exaggerating sorry yeah and you're
showing where they are you're not
holding them
you need to get this one checked now it
was just like uncomfortable but it was
just for a film now we're doing a series
so it's gonna be years of my life
interacting with those both do be show
the picture I think we have a picture of
you guys from this yeah right where his
testicles would be yeah look at her
expression she's at least looking at his
face yeah because they you know it's how
much to the old films yes so we showed
in the way they shots all right
everything was built and there was no
green screens actors were there I think
that makes it easier I mean I would
think would maybe do you have a pair of
balls yes unless you have a pair of
balls right in front of you that's
always the exception to the rule no I'm
really happy I'm doing that yeah back to
that world oh and your son your son must
be happy too not yet he doesn't believe
in me anymore
so he has to watch it and stay till the
end and see like okay so you don't die
in this one right right thank you your
son's tough oh he's he's my son's like
that too
nothing everything I do and he's like
huh you're an ass no everything
everything I do yeah yeah it's complete
contempt for me I think it's healthy
uh-huh yeah it is healthy yeah he'll
never get my money but it's healthy
[Applause]